Phil so the electorate is a pretty just
pleased to tend to be that way in polls
though right yeah that's true you look
people are never really super happy with
how things are going but right now I
think there's a definite you can see it
in the numbers right now that it's deep
and who benefits from that no one else
but Donald Trump and it's not just
Donald Trump but it's also the outsiders
in general this is a theme we've seen
donnie over the last couple weeks where
you see Donald Trump once again in the
Bloomberg politics national poll out
front at twenty-one percent following
him closely behind is ben Carson and
it's Ben Carson's rise over the last
three weeks it's been probably most
impressive because he's come from single
digits into a legitimate number two
candidate the other one that I was
actually interested to look at here
obviously Carly Fiorina up ten points
since our August pulled to eleven
percent had a great debate performances
tried to parlay that into big
fundraising in the last couple of days
you're going to see more of her but
there's also going to be a lot more
pressure on her coming forward and of
course the zodiac poll was taken after
the CNN debate right yeah this is a
Bloomberg politics pulled on it was
taken after the CNN debate so these are
the newest numbers we've got one of the
interesting things that I like to pick
out of all of these numbers right now is
favorability ratings but I don't
understand why ben Carson has risen
right he's a retired neurosurgeon no
political experience whatsoever just
kind of new to the national scene his
favorability right now sixty-eight
percent just ten percent have an
unfavorable view of him money that's an
absurd number now Marco Rubio also with
a favorability number that's pretty high
but everybody else is in the 50s and 40s
exact you want to know why ben Carson
rises it's because of that I want to
know as well because Trump is a
51-percent favorability and a 40-percent
unfavorable rating so basically is
unfavorable is pretty high as well is
that a good thing no there's a show at
least that is there is a reaction as
opposed to Ben Carson's 10% unfavorables
which might mean that people are better
a pathetic I think what's interesting
about the unfavorables is usually what
happens is a candidate when he's new
will have high favorables and low
unfavorables people like him when he
bursts out of the scene and then it
starts dropping down we've seen it with
Hillary Clinton her poll numbers and her
favorability has dropped over 10 points
in the last three months how Ben
Carson's favorability drops now that
he's kind of jumped onto the national
scene money that's when I'm interested
to watch over the next couple
Washington has goes down I imagine Phil
for the Pope's visit yeah yeah no no
question about a big day yesterday at
the White House but today the joint
meeting of Congress very interesting to
watch